[Music]
welcome back so we're talking about the
Fourier transform as a method of
approximating continuous functions f of
X on some infinite domain from negative
infinity to infinity so let's call this
f of X and we have shown that this
Fourier transform can be thought of as a
Fourier series where you take the
periodic domain from minus L to L and
you take the limit as L goes to infinity
so in the last lectures we derived this
Fourier transform pair so it's
relatively straightforward to go from
some function of X to a to its Fourier
transform this F hat of a frequency
variable Omega and if you had this
Fourier transform F hat you could go
back to the space domain f of X but one
of the things I think is particularly
useful about the Fourier transform one
of the reasons it's so useful for us is
how it transforms derivatives ok so if I
look at the Fourier transform of the
derivative of some function of X DDX of
f of X there's going to be a nice
formula for how this transforms under
the Fourier transform ok so what we're
gonna do is we're literally gonna take
this formula for the Fourier transform
this integral formulation and we're
gonna replace f of X with DF DX ok and
then we're gonna do some some calculus
and see what pops out ok so this is
going to be the integral from negative
infinity to infinity now of DF DX e to
the minus I Omega X DX good and now what
we're gonna do is we're going to
integrate this by parts ok so we're
going to consider this remember the
integral of U DV equals UV minus the
integral of VDU
that's integration by parts and so here
what we're gonna do we're going to let
this be you and we're gonna let this be
the D V and when we integrate by parts
what we're going to get is UV ok so the
integral of D
is just if DV is df/dx then V is just F
and so this equals u times V so that's f
of x times e to the minus I Omega X
that's you V and you always take that
evaluated at the bounds of integration
so that's from minus infinity to
infinity and then minus the integral of
VDU minus the integral from minus
infinity to infinity V D U and V again
is just f of X and D U now if you take
the the derivative of U with respect to
X you get a minus I Omega I'm just gonna
write this minus I Omega e to the minus
I Omega X okay that's DV so I'm just
gonna put a little under braces around
this so we remember what we're talking
about this is V and this is D u okay so
all we've done here is we've taken the
Fourier transform of the derivative of F
with respect to X and we're using our
simple integration by parts formula so
we're letting the DF DX be my DV and my
e to the minus I Omega X be that you
that equals UV evaluated of the bounds
of integration minus the integral of VDU
good and now you're gonna see that this
minus and this minus they're gonna
cancel that's nice
so there's an important part of this
that I I want to point out which is so e
to the minus I Omega X for all X this is
this is a comp for all real valued X
this is a complex and a purely imaginary
exponent and so e to the I anything is
going to give you cosines and sines and
the kind of length of this complex
number the the norm of this complex
number is going to be one okay it's
going to be on a circle with a different
angle given by minus Omega X okay so
this at most has length one okay and
it's multiplied
by f of X this is a very important
property of the Fourier transform that I
need to tell you is that your function f
of X has to decay to zero at plus and
minus infinity this only makes sense
this Fourier transform pair only makes
sense if f of X decays to zero at as X
goes to positive and negative infinity
ok so the way I drew it here where this
this hat function dies out to 0 those
are the only kinds of functions you can
represent where they die out to 0 so
this f of X evaluated at plus infinity
or minus infinity has to be equal to 0
and it's multiplied by e to a purely
imaginary number so that's 0 times
something that has norm one is equal to
0 and so this is going to equal zero at
those bounds of integration and so this
entire integral expression now is going
to equal just all of this stuff here
so my minuses cancel and I get a plus
negative infinity to infinity
since this integral is with respect to
DX I can pop my Iomega out so this is an
I Omega integral negative infinity to
infinity of f of X e to the minus I
Omega X DX and this is really nice this
expression here this entire integral
here is just the Fourier transform of f
of X this is just the Fourier transform
of f of X and so what we get after this
entire procedure this chain rule
procedure is that the Fourier transform
of the derivative of a function is just
I Omega times the Fourier transform of
the function itself ok so this is equal
to the Fourier transform of DF DX ok
that's an extremely useful property so
what that means is that if I have some
function f of X I can compute its
derivative in the Fourier domain much
much more easily in some cases for
example I just Fourier transform my
function I multiply that that function
by I Omega
so if my derivative becomes a
multiplication in the Fourier domain I
take my my Fourier transform and I just
multiply it by I Omega and that's the
Fourier transform of the derivative of
my function okay and we're gonna find
that this is actually very useful for
computations sometimes I can compute
this derivative more accurately in the
Fourier transform domain if sometimes I
can approximate df/dx more accurately by
first for you transforming f then
multiplying by I Omega and then inverse
for you transforming okay so that's a
frequent thing we do that's called the
spectral derivative and we're gonna code
that up in matlab and python we're gonna
see that it's more accurate than doing a
finite difference central difference for
difference or backward difference
derivative like you would normally do
okay so that's particularly useful it's
also really nice because you can
transform partial differential equations
into ordinary differential equations
this way so this is really cool if I
have some PDE like UT T equals some
constant u X X so this is just the the
wave equation okay so u as a function of
T and of X of time and of space and if I
Fourier transform so this is a PDE if I
Fourier transform in space so let's take
Fourier in X then what I'm gonna get is
U hat time derivative so I didn't
Fourier transform in time I just Fourier
transformed in space but now if I take
this function this X derivative if I
take two x derivatives I get an I
squared Omega squared times the Fourier
transform of U and so I squared Omega
squared is just minus Omega squared u
hat okay and so what this means is that
now I have an OD e in the Fourier
transform variable okay so I took my
original system I Fourier transformed in
space and now I don't have partial
derivatives anymore I just have time
derivatives equals a function this is an
ordinary differential equation and just
to see this a little bit more clearly I
want to be very
mayu was a function of X and T and when
I Fourier transformed I get u hat which
is a function of Omega and T okay so
that's what I mean when I say I Fourier
transform in X is I do this Fourier
integral with respect to the X variable
and I swap out space for a spatial wave
number a spatial frequency Omega and now
you can convince yourself that if I take
the partial derivative of either of
these with respect to time I can
essentially pass a derivative with
respect to time anywhere I like in this
inner algo I can bring it inside the
integral or outside the integral because
my time derivative commutes with my
integral for space with respect to space
okay
and so what that means is that if I
Fourier transform with respect to space
this u hat now is a function of Omega
and T and so u hat I can still take
partial derivatives in time and now I
get an ordinary differential equation in
fact I get one ordinary differential
equation for each Omega for every Omega
this is just an Eau de in time okay this
is like u double dot equals minus Omega
u and I can compute that that the
solution of that ordinary differential
equation ok so very very useful property
of the Fourier transform is that the
Fourier transform of the derivative of a
function is just I Omega times the
Fourier transform of that function and I
can use that either to approximate
derivatives numerically very accurately
or I can also use that to transform
partial differential equations into
ordinary differential equations okay so
we're going to explore this more with
some numerical examples in a bit all
right thank you